I think it's really nice command cut out  a better performance than you so  obviously we're really disappointed with  their and it's good to see that we came  out with a lot more site today today we  put in a bit of a bit more of better  effort and just checking the stats then  we had 16 gold shops to their three so  you know so many apart from the first  quarter I thought we played pretty well  neurons really enjoyed that we've had so  much help it's been so easy coming down  here and a lot of little extra touches  just to make our lives easier which is  really nice we do genuinely enjoy coming  for smaller centres to play because and  as we saw today the crowd really does  get behind us so yes for us differently  it is nice to come to smaller centres  and yeah be able to play in front of us  so proud obviously we're over and final  dress after so it's nice to get that  interaction with them and yeah hopefully  to inspire them to want to apply to  collect us one day  [Music]